yacht au monde c'est squeeze et
aujourd'hui on se trouve sur quatre
mario 3d voilà son 3d du jeu jugé qu est
ce que ça peut donner ou là il se
trouvera combat-là dragon ball z la
salle pas du tout ok donc effectivement
c'est bien de là c'est comme ça qu'ils
décèdent là il est décédé est très
trompeur c'est mon ancien moi ça ça va
être la galère je le sens mais c'est de
chuter ce truc battant mais reviens ici
je n'étais pas de donner la permission
de t'envoler l'alanine ja oui mais non
mais non mais j'aurais pu rebondir
dessus [ __ ] les gars mais quelle forme
de ballon bon là il s'est pris un peu
pour un rouleau petit c'est quoi je
t'écrase et je t'écrase je t'écrase
encore ça va
hop la maison mes mecs mais un pokémon
qui sort de nulle part qui m'écrase mais
emmène en bosses ya pas un [ __ ] de
cumin non non non de se cacher dans
l'espace
il manquerait plus qu'il y laisse l'état
chanter quoi
bridzar up tandjaoui en fait s'en va ils
sont d'accord ils disparaissent arche
boum boum boum c'était ça passe brigade
mais wang n'ont tourné dans la vie lui
en fait s'il attend comme un [ __ ] de
fourbe à celle du copain ça va ça se
trouve j'étais un truc invisible vous
peut-être pas bah oui ça me fait rire
mais pas tant que ça en fait
en fait jamais monsieur barry jamais ça
devait pleurer quoi je pense qu'il faut
faire une sorte de sphère tellement pas
ça faut vraiment sauté et là ok en fait
lui nous gêne dans le seau donc d'après
non c'est un calcul là que je fais alors
attendez pas d mais on peut double
sautée meiway aucun aux pgm
mais on peut double sautée me le dise
même pas bon en fait c'était simplement
rien du tout quoi mais vous la presse
euh j'ai cru que ça allait me tuer je
l'appliqué sur eux mais j'étais un peu
fébrile
attends je me retrouve qu'est ce qui
s'est passé entre temps au quartz donc
appuyé sur eux que tu vraiment eu le bac
imtu en l'air couaillet cette
modélisation à base de pâte à modeler
quoi sans déconner
l'info mais non mais tu chantes
actionnaires quand la pluie surtout par
des pâtes
[Musique]
comment je fais je suis tellement
traumatisée que je suis resté appuyé sur
la touche je la lâche plus voilà je suis
un peu de guitare avec notre boulet
comme j'ai le réflexe de rester appuyer
ses dires une quoi j'appelle jardin
qu'il fallait pas je crois mais je sais
que ce mode remettait les couleurs mais
je veux plus que l'écran défi et je
meurs en boucle mais [ __ ] mais c'est
pas un jeu ça s'appelle une image à des
quatre stages en bateau juste atteint
jargeau des stades 22 quoi à chaque
faute une fois pardon sourit pas dit non
3 contre 1 120 contraint à laymont poule
à aller là il arrive pour faire 1 2 1
il me touche et arrêter de regarder
comme ça je crois que vos [ __ ] au la
rentrée donc aux îles arriver nulle part
celui-là a mais arrête de lécher le
[ __ ] de côté de ce cube ça pas de goût
c'est du carton mais [ __ ] la china
limited groupe bana nous citerons pas
trop ne voyage pas comme ça tu voles je
m'étonne que je perde après le mec qui
volent j'ai fait tout ce qui était dans
mon pouvoir n'ont fait pas sien je crois
que c'est pas très bon pour elle est
sortie ça va quoi bientôt il y aura plus
de mecha dahak que des monstres qui ont
d'ailleurs disparu y sommes
et pourquoi ils veulent du mal à ce chat
tout mignon faut sauter au dessus vous
pensez stage un stage à mettet que
gilles pache mai d'abaisser non j'ai
sauté pour l'esquivé la porte elle à
fait d'accord avec vous mon imitation de
la porte c'est très bien voilà illimité
de porte pas si simple que ça
don't panic local panique la peur quand
même
tac non j'aime bien je préfère mourir
comme ça
bandes de filles non quand tu fais le
tfca tenue de quitter le programme ça
mais jeu en pause j'ai pas du tout riche
et une cheminée mais non mais non mais
non mais non mais non mais [ __ ] je
sens le troll de ou quoi oh mais non
gosse aux règles ça c'est déjà un
exploit [ __ ] la banane jours de prison
est là elle sort depuis sinon voilà puis
c'est d'accord me regardez pas comme ça
je sais qu'on peut y arriver je le sea
food in home mais c'est de plus en plus
longs et dernier je le passe passe et ça
au [ __ ] comment vous voulez continuer
il reste trois dans vatan le dernier
c'est un cheveu quoi je joue pour et ben
on va être l'autre côté c'est pas du
tout ce que j'ai perdu peut tout juste
sait pas par pure curiosité watts
non je refuse de mourir dans ces
conditions c'est un métier d'architecte
de cette maison je veux tenter de
rentrer par le trou c'est un échec total
c'est la dudh u2 lui défoncer haguenau
stage 2 c'est bon je me calme
attendez est-ce que j'ai juste de
comprendre ce qui s'est passé
s'il vous plaît et je vous permet en
tous les cas je meurs quoi jeu pour
atterrir sur un [ __ ] de matelas que je
mourrais n'ont-ils sur moi
[Musique]
non mais
ce casque ne m'est d'aucune utilité
holnon mec ça c'est parce que j'ai pris
mon casse au nom
elle m'a mis une petite oie
voilà je me replace à une cravate
invisible donc à mes [ __ ] j'aimerais
que tu viens de me chercher quoi pas
regarder on dirait qu'il est un petit
blouson en cuir moulant en ligne comme
ça pourquoi un chat aussi mignon galère
autant dans la vie pourrait pas j'espère
comme tout les chapou fait dormir jouer
dormir bouffer de la swan aller fin de
vidéo je vous souhaite une très bonne
fin de journée
cordialement je m'en vais je peux pas
finir comme ça moi j'espère qu'elle vous
aura plu c'est le cas n'hésitez pas à
nous mais ça fera pas au plaisir c'est
vrai que j'ai pas beaucoup argumenté 1
mais bon vous dire dans mon cerveau il
soit c'est un peu ça on se retrouvait
dans une nouvelle vidéo tu as tout le
monde
pis aïe ça fait mal je m'en veux et
voilà
[Musique]
et